revenir sur ce qui s'est passé
exactement mais pour vous montrer un
petit peu l'ambiance je vous propose de
regarder ces quelques images ou petro
porochenko qui est le président de
l'ukraine revient sur les tensions avec
la russie
il ne parle pas de cet incident naval
sur lequel on va revenir mais dit il ya
bien d'autres choses
il ya carrément des chars russes qui se
massent à sa frontière et ça ça
n'inquiète regarder ses yeux ce matin
c'est la courbe acheter qik estime qu'il
n'a pas à cliquer le special one in the
nation corps donne zéro cela reach sit
in qui a marqué à boeing
alors va revenir sur le conflit général
mais rené girard à ce que vous voulez
bien vous approchez de la carte qui est
là pour nous rappeler en quelques
instants
ce qui s'est passé dimanche dernier
pourquoi c'est un pourquoi c'est un
problème bien il ya une petite flotille
en fait avec un remorqueur et deux
petits canonnière si vous voulez de
petits bateaux armés qui ont quitté
odessa en pleine ukraine pour aller
déjeuner et goûter pour que nos
téléspectateurs dans une autre ville
d'ukraine qui est mario paul qui est une
ville qui n'a pas été prise lorsqu'il ya
eu l'offensive des rebelles pro russes
qui ont pris donc les
ces partis sont grisés du dombass
donetsk est lougansk deux districts du
dombass voilà et le problème c'est que
il y à là à pont le pont le 15 c'est à
dire que les russes se sont saisis de la
crimée en mars 2014 après un référendum
à un homme qui n'a pas qui était massif
d'approbation parce que la pollution de
crimée et pro russe mais qui n'a pas été
reconnue par la communauté
internationale
donc la russie a pris la crimée mais
elle ne pouvait la ravitailler que par
la mer puisqu'il avait pas de continuité
territoriale à la russie s'arrête la fin
et donc ils ont construit un pont qui
était inaugurée en mai dernier par le
président poutine de 19 km sur le
détroit de kertch et simplement il ya
des ukrainiens qui étaient contre
l'existence de ce bond qui ont dit
qu'ils allaient le dynamite et donc les
russes ont décidé de faire des
inspections à tous les bateaux qui
rentreraient dans la mer d'azov en
passant sous sous ce pont notamment pour
rejoindre le port ukrainien 2
mario paul or ce qui s'est passé c'est
que cette petite flottille a voulu
échapper n'est pas au contrôle
c'est simon chez elles vont voir que là
le cren reconnaît pas l'annexion de la
crimée a voulu échapper au contrôle de
des gardes côtes russes et donc a été
bousculé un bateau qui était bousculé il
ya eu des tirs mais pas directement pour
tuer c'était des tirs de semonce ou d'un
bond pour impressionner pour intimider
et les trois bateaux ukrainiens ont été
conduits de force dans un port de cayx
tout ça a commencé
il faut le bien de le voir en mars en
mars 2018
il y à un bateau de pêche qui venait de
crimée et qui a été arraisonné par des
bateaux de guerre ukrainien
et c'est à partir de ce moment là
comment représailles si vous voulez que
les russes ont institué ce contrôle sur
le détroit de série chère ne vous
propose de rejoindre votre place et
pendant que vous vous installez alors
j'étais pas qu'ils se sont suffisamment
familier du sujet pour vous dire si à
son avis il ya un risque de guerre à
partir de cet incident maxime d'égailler
je suis je suis pas un spécialiste
de cette question est ce qu'il ya un
risque de guerre je note mois qu' il y
avait une désescalade
quand même depuis les accords de ming
que la communauté internationale
aujourd'hui il fait preuve de moins de
fermeté que
il y à une tentative au delà de
l'annexion de la crimée de la part de la
russie de revendiquer les eaux
territoriales et qu'il serait
j'ai à dire de bonne guerre mais la
formule très malheureuse il serait
nécessaire que nous puissions de nouveau
parler d'une seule voix quand je dis
nous c'est notamment l'allemagne et la
france qui ont été à l'origine de
désaccords et j'ai noté une position
ferme de l'allemagne ouvrant la
possibilité de sanctions vis-à-vis de la
russie ça me semble important j'ai pas
noté la même fermeté du côté des
françaises de drian puisque si j'ai bien
compris il a eu des échanges récents et
la parole était un peu plus faible ce
qui est préoccupant parce que je ne
pense pas qu'on arrive à la guerre par
contre on sait bien qu'aujourd'hui la
russie essaie de profiter de la
faiblesse relative notamment de l'europe
pour consolider ces positions qui sont
des compositions aujourd'hui qui
nécessitent d'être combattue puisque
effectivement ils ont annexé un
territoire qui est un crime et alors on
vous a posé la question sur twitter
selon vous une guerre est elle possible
entre l'ukraine et la russie
vous nous dites oui à 59% c'est un sujet
qui vous intéresse beaucoup il ya
beaucoup de commentaires
il ya macabre nitot qui nous dit on a
bien vu que personne n'a réagi avec
l'annexion de la crimée sous-entendu les
russes peuvent faire ce qu'ils veulent
c'est aussi l'avis de monsieur babineau
qui nous dit il n'y aura pas de guerre
l'armée russe est beaucoup trop forte et
fouquet nous dit on ne pourra pas parler
de guerre les russes seront à kiev avant
que les journaux aient eu le temps d'en
rendre compte
renaud girard pour vous il ya un risque
de guerre où on en reste à des mesures
d'intimidation là très clairement en
fait c'est une petite provocation des
ukrainiens qui peuvent se comprendre
pour qu'on n'oublie pas le cas le cas de
l'ukraine et pour qu'on en parle et donc
de nous dire qu'on en parle au conseil
de sécurité des nations unies moi je ne
pense pas qu'une politique de sanctions
puissent faire changer la stratégie d'un
pays comme la russie qui a quand même
tenu pendant 1000 jours au siège de
leningrad face à l'armée allemande ont
fait pas changer des rues g 500 qui sort
déjà et ce sera aussi par ailleurs je
remarque que les sanctions commerciales
pénalise la france puisque la part de
marché de la france en russie a diminué
de 34% alors que la part de marché de
l'allemagne comme par hasard augmenté de
2%
c'est la région ça mc sociale
pourquoi il faudrait faire je pense que
je pense que vladimir poutine se rend
compte qu'il a commis une erreur
stratégique en investissant le dombass
la région l'a donc que je montrais à
partir de face les rebelles pro russe
puis l'armée russe qui est intervenu
clandestinement à partir d'août 2014 je
pense que c'est une erreur stratégique
mais je pense qu'il faudrait en fait dit
les c'est-à-dire de 10 rebonds parce
qu'en fait l'obsession de la russie
c'est de garder l'ukraine comme un
glacis voilà et leur obsession c'est que
c'est que l'ukraine ne rentre jamais
dans l'otan il est vrai qu il eu des
promesses qui ont été faites d'ailleurs
à paris par le président achebouche
gorbatchev que jamais le temps ne
s'étendrait vers ces pays de l'est où se
retirer à l'époque en 1990 les forces
russes soviétique et met donc moi je
pense qu'on pourrait faire un deal en
disant bon l'ukraine n'en saura jamais
dans le temps on est bien d'accord mais
vous vous retirez donc vous rendez les
les territoires et notamment la
frontière ukraino-russe aux forces
iraniennes
quant à la crimée et bien ça sera un
deal entre les ukrainiens et les russes
dans 20 ans il faut bien voir que les
russes ne rendrons jamais la crimée
crime et ne reviendra jamais l'ukraine
comme le kosovo ne reviendra jamais la
serbie il faut rappeler que le kosovo a
été arrachée à la serbie par une
opération militaire auzits n'est pas de
l'otan entre mars et juin merci on va
revoir la carte pour qu'on comprenne
bien tout ce que vous nous avez dit donc
la zone que les russes pourraient rendre
en signe de bonne volonté c'est donc
celle qui se trouve à la frontière
kubel de la crème voilà sélective que
jamais qu'ils ont jamais accepté
d'annexer la zone qui est en pointe
l'est de donetsk julia de funès votre
avis sur ce sujet mon avis si je
reprends les moines mesure on peut
encore dit les comme vous avez dit donc
parler de guerre ça me semble improbable
parce que si on peut dire et ça veut
dire qu'on a encore des intérêts des
deux côtés et ce ne sont jamais les
intérêts qui déclenche les guerres ce
sont les passions tout dans l'histoire
humaine se sont à chaque fois des
passions qui ont déclenché les guerres
passion de la patrie d idéologie
religieuse nationaliste de révolution
peu importe la passion mais ce ne sont
jamais pour le sait n'a jamais été pour
le pétrole pour l'argent pour les
matières premières qu on a déclenché des
guerres donc temps que des intérêts ne
se transforme pas en passion aveugle
à mon avis on est loin de la guerre
encore bon et je passais par là anti mac
qui remercie renault gérard pour son
sens de la pédagogie
nous aussi d'ailleurs jérôme
sainte-marie point de vue purement
française d'hier les comment les
représentations s'organise autour de
cette question de la russie et
accessoirement de l'ukraine en france
est absolument fascinant on a eu ce
témoignage à l'instant sur le plateau de
voir à quel point la gauche ou plus
précisément le parent socialiste adopte
une position résolument pro otan en
toute matière c'est absolument fascinant
de voir que françois hollande est allé
jusqu'à ne pas envoyer de délégation
française pour le 9 mai sur la place
rouge pour l'anniversaire de la seconde
guerre mondiale enfin la victoire que
l'on doit comme d'ailleurs en grande
partie la victoire de 14-18 au sacrifice
de millions de russes
il est très intéressant de voir un
discours optimiste pour autant être vos
l'otan il ya effectivement un grand
discours sur les valeurs qui tombe
complètement à côté d'une part parce que
le passo chine ne s'oppose pas à
certaines élections territoriales
ailleurs y compris au proche orient que
par ailleurs en tout cas pas très
vivement que par ailleurs et bien on ne
vous entend pas par ailleurs me dis à
personne que par ailleurs de tendre
l'oreille pour rester sur la russie que
effectivement même la question
ukrainienne que le on a adopté un récit
sur maidan et sur l'ukraine qui est
assez surprenant c'est la plage hier à
laquelle il y avait eu ces affrontements
entre ukrainiens pro russe et ukrainien
pro occidentaux que je l'étais
d'ailleurs en 2004 s'est tu quand
j'étais étudiant voyez que j'ai des amis
et d'ailleurs nous avons maintenant une
offre qui est d'adapter asleigh monsieur
glucksmann puisque l'espace public qui
ne voit aucun problème à adopter le
point de vue d'un gouvernement et d'une
majorité dans lequel il ya des éléments
qui ne sont pas pro nazi en réalité ils
sont en asie c'est à dire
qu'effectivement ils défilent en
uniforme de division sa sérénité qui
soutient à nous asseoir et craignent un
grand pays la shoah par balles dire on
est quand même dans un univers assez
surréaliste où les mêmes qui ont un
discours sur les valeurs et la moyenne
est à l'amour à la mauvaise mémoire
laboral etc en france en ukraine comme
on efface un espèce de démons totalement
fantasmé sur la russie mais ça je veux
pas parler la russie mais ni ben des
représentations c'est fascinant ce
double standard où effectivement quand
il s'agit de contrer la russie et
d'adopter le point vue l'otan alors là
on est une transformation totale du
devoir de mémoire et le lendemain sur
safari c'est qu'a fait c'est vrai que
dans cette controverse dans cette danse
est de ceux des dégénérescences si vous
voulez en ukraine au donbass à partir de
juin juillet 2014 effectivement pour
mater des rebelles pro russe des
ukrainiens du donbass mme qui était pro
russe on a envoyé notamment des
bataillons est certes un bataillon
notamment le baptême d'azov était
composé de voir demain nazis ont
vertement nostalgie que là c'est vrai il
y avait d'ailleurs eu un reportage là
dessus sur le figaro magazine on
rappellera que le conflit dans le
donbass a fait dix mille morts nous
passons